10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 0
you
[Music]
so now I have sound right why what the
heck okay so what I said earlier
you didn't hear anyway I was just saying
that it took me about to do a new video
couple of reasons
Internet has been unstable him a little
bit and the other thing was was just too
nice outside yeah to stay inside and do
videos so and now I'm sitting here in my
hotel room and it's raining outside so a
good moment to do a video yeah this is
our Lee blitz arena what am I going to
play for here I am some some kind of d5
probably maybe immediately no why not he
didn't do anything to prevent me from
playing d5 so why not Bishop is on g7 at
least protecting me five I can always
take here and probably be roughly equal
Jim it's maybe a little bit simple
simple meaning I'm not posing many
problems but bet okay I mean this this
position is certainly fine for black
let's see I'm a little bit reluctant and
playing b5 I think that would mostly
just weaken my queen side so my interest
in doing that is quite low the Knight f5
now gets interesting I could have done
that maybe even
after he played Quincy won because of
the night b3 idea hmm okay
and now he's probably ready to play
before so I should take more control me
get to see for now yeah this looks okay
he's got Bishop c5 but yeah yeah I can
just go Queen d7 I was just thinking if
I have something fancy and I give up the
Queen er so it's completely yeah
probably
probably ridiculous this is about about
equal of course but I'm a little bit
behind on the clock lost about a minute
because of the microphone issue yeah he
just wants to get whooped he won and I
tried to irritate him here by entering
on the Queen side if he takes Queen
takes those pawns are somewhat
vulnerable he has moved those pawns
forward and it didn't help white I think
that looks a bit strange
we're going to see four also looks
technically weird but maybe I don't have
anything fancy but okay what is his next
move actually I can play something
useful Bishop h6 being the idea and
maybe age for the right moment push the
knight back from the cover of e4 this is
actually the most severe idea which is
addressed okay so yeah do I go up t3
here yeah annoy him a little bit yes so
and now this now Bishop e3 is not a good
move as I'm on in d3 gets a little bit
annoying now I've got to push up
d2 also and b6
after which it is completely unclear
about what the bishop is doing Bishop e3
is not very nice yeah why this under
some pressure now I don't I don't know
maybe you can do something clever no
nothing so I take him and now what's the
deal h4 is not good yeah I guess I could
just play Queen to b6 and a couple of
good good moves actually
maybe this one getting this 2d6
one minutes 23 years is not so nice the
clock situation 96 my my work might not
have all that many squares maybe him try
multi-tool
mmm yeah it's definitely nice for morph
of like but I would like to have a
little bit more time to figure it out
[Music]
[Music]
before now is under attack
okay
I'm not sure about this I can also take
their butts probably not an idea
and it's not easy for me to cover this
how does he cover you for I don't see
how now Queen age four I can take III as
well so one this pawn can win this now
also let's do it king of to you maybe I
have got Queen c6 if I don't see
anything better
look f3 is very close to working I don't
know maybe it does work I need to speed
up a little bit
Queen f2 we have got this um yeah this
is the thing I don't see anything good
here f7 is hanging
this person is just clearly better for
black anyway but I've got 14 seconds
something like he can take I can't take
only five now and you should take only
five just that I have 13 seconds this is
a position rate that you can just play
and I don't need anything fancy I'm just
better with 11 seconds yeah yeah I'm not
better oops what did you do that it's a
little bit unclear 7 seconds is enough
for me
[Music]
and it's weird I mean it kind of that's
how the game went then it was a pretty
pretty clear affair but due to the time
yeah like I lost one minutes because of
the microphone but anyway let's see what
happens now um not really
that's not good yeah what's going on
there was a somewhat that was a long
game right that was the thing
[Applause]
okay follow me relatively safe berserk I
have to get into stride again haven't
haven't played at all in the last couple
of days let's see if philidor's yeah
this is usually associated with with
alarm I think is set up with g6 it's
actually pretty questionable for black
yeah just what about this one d6 I can
actually paint during the during the
game I this is not something that I
really have that's not part of my usual
routine let same interesting move here
Yemenite doesn't have all that many
squares
it's got roof he ain't coming up he but
that just castle first it's hard to
believe that this should be any good for
black problem is that I'm serving with 5
minutes on the clock I would be
extremely confident here that this that
I can refute this and the time given but
hmm
23 years also maybe I should have played
that is there any nice tactic here I can
go with these six in this position just
just just treat you know I'm not trading
it's the wrong expression
I'm just winning stuff 96 night night be
seven had also would have won stuff but
now I'm a piece of Queen d2
I should have gone Queen d2 would have
been a tad easier not a big problem or
anything but still would have been
simpler
now let's get this night-night around
taking one if five would be good just
get rid of a couple of active pieces
that he has left 97 yeah 97 and between
the four will also trade Queens that
makes it simple
okay
yeah it's just for no pack mates it's
about the only way to still screw it up
is to run into some kind of background
made while still meeting is also a good
a good thing that that you could do okay
so where's some mate
okay I just I just get the Queen and
it's probably the easiest okay so second
place coding and lifting as quickly
winning these games
noxee okay I know g6 actually OB 3 I
don't think that works really I think
there is a problem with this I'm not
sure this is the problem but I have to
be quick about it
yeah maybe 4 is still ok yeah I can take
here nothing wrong about it I think
okay I cannot take you far though maybe
him
it's a bits it accident sister maybe a
bit too complicated I should have done
something simpler just because of the
time ye 595 six this kind of stuff
[Music]
okay so at least has no age 5 and e6
immediately
and isn't he firing with what's the deal
the Queen should not be able to attack
both nights even attacking one night is
not so easy
twin c1 or something looks wrong okay
very stupid
I mean I didn't see this coming um yes
fantastic
Wow of extremely unnecessary you can
just not take your phone be just clearly
better great weirwood with the with the
center pawns and so on
very stupid play okay
and I was losing some material anyway so
I'm going for this I couldn't play it
like just being an exchange down didn't
work what is he thinking about
the ship CTools I only move anyway or
what's idea
whoa why what what was wrong with Bishop
c2 I mean I can take take the rook on
but it's a bit strange
and now I'm winning almost 93 also in
what was wrong with bishops each one I
don't I don't know
maybe 93 was better yeah it's probably
not a big difference I mean what what
what move is why it's supposed to play
now the the night is just hanging
he couldn't really prevent this and this
is a pretty huge fault he won't see one
nf2 so this one
yeah 35 seconds not great but it is
reasonably simple to win trying to f4 I
wanted to play actually in box him in
dr. e5 yeah
quite quite weird I was just I mean I
wasn't a mouse looked more like a brain
slip I wanted to play a form
94 what the heck I'm really screwing
this up yeah fantastic
I'm not screwing it up but I tried hard
those made them meet next move
okay so second place but this person is
winning all the games new account
just winning quicker oops
it didn't play d5 wow it looks pretty
strange we get some some sort of French
defense where um like pieces look a bit
weird hmm yeah can try it to directly
sacrifice I could work I mean it I mean
it could work I'm playing it in a way
that I almost have to do it next move
but it looks quite dangerous
really
now I've got all kinds of discoveries if
I take this he's got he can go to the
eighth
that's probably probably the idea but I
have Queen to g7 at the end that were
just wedding stuff
so he cannot go to the 8th King the edge
screen g7 just wins material and King f8
it would be weird if it works ok so no
g5 is one way to do it maybe that's not
not extremely clear and it takes
[Music]
hmm 95 he can take on g5 take on g4
that's that's a bit of a pain okay yeah
I need to look he's got Bishop e8 this
is actually um what made me pause him
and now I have to go back which is not
ideal it's still a pretty good attack
but it's not convincing
you know 96 easy
[Music]
try the spoon yeah I still think this is
actually good for me but it's not easy
to play it's not just a straight win or
anything
push-up just six so maybe and maybe this
is actually not good for me arrow now
that I see Bishop g6 coming
hmm 40 seconds
checks I can take and take and take on
d5 it's so pretty
good attack him and he can get tons of
ways to completely screw it up I think
it actually should win now why is he
going with the coin I can take on his
six most of the time 27 maybe it's
relatively best or this one but that
also looks a bit strange isn't that
winning the Queen he might just give the
Queen now
he's got some material for it if I can
get the pawns f5 and so ff6 if I can get
that in I'm winning down
the points that will break blacks
coordination entirely and I think I can
manage
it's not bad to have this with chick can
play Queen jf4 maybe with check if he
goes on the dark square and just have
six yeah just have six also strong
96 and it just pushed those plans maybe
I should have checked first a duck it's
it's it's fine
time still a bit of a problem
hmm it was helpful
nine seconds it's not the quickest way
to do it
but it's enough mochi
I was an imported win they don't want
clear at all
maybe the peace sacrifice was good but I
wasn't entirely sure okay yeah red line
and against them against the London
playing quite often black must be fine
him but it's not it's not an advantage
show anything I mean White's position is
super solid always feel Knight c3 and
worked you won't make us someone we get
impression but it is okay for white
and the ticket defy you will take b7
song cannot just grab the pawn
yeah it looks fine I should been taking
this twice yeah I was thinking night
before look at D 5 D 3 huh I'm still the
7th pawn looks a little bit yeah it's
not that great if I get a little bit of
time to regroup I'm fine but maybe just
rookie one ok see if I can to see five
or so I'm not really sure how to
position my pieces he can he cannot move
his PT 3 bishop sc2 is hanging I think
this one okay
huh okay now a2 is hanging they don't
see why I shouldn't take it Bishop d2
Mamie
93 looks a little bit shaky looks a
little bit shaky and I can go back and
still have 93 I mean in order to win the
night he has to attack it first and UK
one doesn't work some okay is still not
attacking it
okay I don't have a six available
slightly annoying mover really and this
is pinned
that's not so good somehow this isn't
doesn't look all that grade okay I have
to get rid of this as no other you know
why the choice I think I still have c3
and before as squeeze for the night but
before it's not too safe a square Evan
yeah but that should be okay
it's so not an easy part to convert by
any means a claim you know but now I'm
threatening to take the night and I'm
threatening this which is a pretty big
Fork
again you know that should be winning
material now quite substantial material
actually oh oh and a connection problem
yeah Adam the internet wasn't all that
stable last couple of days and also when
the weather is getting bad here I mean
really if we have like a thunderstorm
the internet usually here doesn't work
at all because it simply gets turned off
the problem is that we are I mean we're
not high here on a mountain or something
but it is clearly above ground 300 or
something meters and you think that yeah
light lightning might strike and this
happened before here in this place they
got a lightning
they've got lightning damage and it
makes sense to turn off the internet so
the damage is somewhat limited okay I'm
just to piss up him
could have taken d5 have would have been
a bit easier anyway this is still not
difficult of course oh no I'm not that
not blunder oh please
yeah my position is very
well-coordinated some should be able to
win one of the two points him to go for
an attack myself queen d1 oh it's a
chicken okay so I'm leading and here
coding and lifting actually lost two
games in the meantime that's good news
my main concern is that some of the
internet gets turned off but we don't
we're not in a thunderstorm you know
it's just like just raining hmm it
wasn't really necessary to berserk this
but it's amazing that people know know
this by now and this line there should
be six is what they usually do Oh does
that have a does that have some sort of
problem I don't know
that still looks very normal ish I don't
have great d5 control the indisposition
even night h7 could be an idea for him
not sure about this was the case of
later
not a bra given forever huh I've got a
d5 I've got controlled but my pieces are
not active I am soon came I was thinking
95 now
it's it's very okay if I'm I took with
the bishop okay that I did not really
expect I was thinking take with the
night rather Kay night will come to see
five
mmm-hmm I have to watch out for the time
okay so he just goes for blocade there
not good say I don't like this position
black it's very okay here with their
five and so on cam don't provoke g6 just
quickly maybe that is part of his
position now I don't play this well at
all not at all mmm yeah black is just
better how do we do this f1 hmm
I don't have a plan in this position I
mean not just that I don't see a plan I
don't think there is a plan it just it
just sucks him
maybe f4 is a way to completely shut
everything down and maybe I can actually
do that if he goes in for I've got 90 46
which is at least a good square but I
mean he can even even sacrifice against
this 93 I'm happily sacrificing myself
maybe I can actually take the air come
on let's do it
that could it could work and it has the
advantage of I can take this I can check
the roof Queen takes there was there was
Queen e6
and Queen h3 is annoying okay let's
color this
and the problem here is that any end
game is sucks here probably because of
my weaknesses I would rather I don't see
how I can answer you should be for this
rookie seven
okay maybe rookie seven rookie eight is
an idea and then moves the rook for
Queenie eight
Brook h74 queenie 17 is got clearly for
cannot do that
queenie seven major now is the threat
candid what what is the move against us
kingi King g7 maybe how they can obtain
can chicken go from the aid hmm I don't
quite see what you should do now
where's the maid hard to believe that
there isn't a maid and now it's got
Queen f-22 Queen c2 now for a draw at
least yeah this isn't made Quincy - he
had to play Quincy to me a job would
have been greater
for from black now that he had NAFTA
allowed to check on his seven okay I was
a bit lucky
so dingdong is on Perseid step but nine
points behind it shouldn't be a problem
I can play one more game comfortably
without any burrs irking
[Music]
see them no pairing I okay um yeah that
just played this without any hectic
this is a line where I think white is
slightly better in fact it's not not
just an equal position where nothing
happens the problem is that white is
getting couples Tempe here and it's not
so easy to coordinate the black position
it's not terrible of course but not easy
to play should be Florida I've got 95
him
[Music]
let's see how to put some pressure here
I'm threatening oh it takes it okay so
this is definitely now better for white
and actually quite substantially maybe
I've got gotten rid of my my structure
is shown the the iqp
and he gave me the bishop Pam we could
try to set up a blockade on the light
squares but we'll see what happens
I cannot go rogue eighty-one currently
because of his bishop so maybe age three
is something that I should do hmm
and I it's okay to go to see b3 I wasn't
entirely sure one thing is he has given
up his dark squared bishop and this
allows 94 to d6 I think this is
something that I should probably do next
yeah let's do this
that must be strong
know that that is very cooperative I
wanted to go there anyway okay
the French exchanged I mean I know the
reputation of this opening but if you
see no some ideas I think it's not so
easy for black at all I mean I didn't
preserve okay I was just thinking four
points no no I get even a new Gaiman
bazooka
[Music]
yeah this is actually not better only
this is better for black this this
Bishop c4 is actually still equal if
white plays correctly afterwards but
most people don't and this is this is a
very good for black the main idea is age
six and then Bishop to a G form can also
yeah can take already um can take let's
do this as many many continuations that
are quite clearly better for black this
is one of them okay seems that he wants
to castle long okay we will go rook g1
probably I wonder if c5 is a move that I
should claim he cannot take it at the
moment like am i should move click him
and minute 42 so kind of tempting Eric
if you get c5 and possibly c4 okay let's
let's do it the move Queen h5 is
irritating me then d5 is hanging but I
can just place his six actually this is
not bad and also he intends to double or
triple or what not okay
yeah this is can take here right King
takes Bishop III but he can take d5 he
answers this is not so easy now Queen d5
let's do this he can take a form this is
all this is a bit more complicated than
I wanted it to be to be honest and this
is a mistake I think he allows me to
play with bieed with the tempo rupee one
made how does he prevent that and I
don't think he can actually cannot
prevent the deaf group be one made
assists coming and just play some
queenie aid or some Queen b3
yeah that's it
[Music]
when it wasn't ordered all that simple
so that's it
fourteen points ahead I am three minutes
you don't get a game in there but you
can still see what then that's not prima
of this I get into some ugly vni game
then happened to me more than once a kid
is the Bishop Bishop before chipped line
95 yeah this is a good continuation and
one of the reasons why I don't like this
line that much anymore but irritated why
is he thinking has to take on b6 okay 94
is probably not worse for white it
wasn't a good idea
I mean not him not a vacation I could
have played t5 actually which and I
should have played to 5 it's still an
okay position can you do something
fancier with the rook
that makes sense that makes sense
yeah I knew this was not the greatest
idea ever
[Laughter]
I can take here and play 95 potentially
prevent some f4 then it's not so bad my
night is actually quite okay then
against this Bishop still nothing
fantastic but still what is he doing
here maybe just play the bishop again to
see - awesome I want to trade anyway
yeah not a bad idea because of the space
disadvantage I don't mind trades ok
Queen h4 ISM extremely non subtle idea
but no ok the second ideas of courses
playlist Knight f6 and trade in this
position ever I get just rooks and
queens on the board is not so bad I can
actually double against the pawn play a
5 I'd rather be black then I mean not
nothing special but yeah this is the
standing it's not interesting anymore
but ok no it doesn't do much not a bad
move actually
take take on d5 next
mm go this is another problem
now this is okay if you get this many
this much traded you're okay in such a
position
yeah Bishop should take and then yeah c6
it looks bad for the d6 pawn but this no
maybe seven there's no other way to
cover this king will go to e7 and cover
d6 and it's okay if I've g5 should be
okay I've got 95 coming normally you can
defend such a position quite quite
comfortably
[Applause]
take okay - something like that
hmm
hmm and probably then the aid I mean one
thing is to every witness on time
probably because why does not even
speeding up a little bit
staking lots of time
it's not very difficult technically I
guess
that's usually the moment where you
blunder the house--a but I think it
shouldn't happen
oops it's it's good that the point is
not on each forehead because it could
have happened stumbling into a mate okay
so I won the tournament with the winning
streak yeah
I'm happy that this worked out because
well I tried one or two tournaments in
recent days and the internet was just
too unstable but this booked out fine
I had just one moment very connected
yeah okay I hope you enjoyed it maybe
I'll do one or two more videos during
the rest of the day CNY in my place
we'll see what happened thanks for
watching
[Applause]